hi welcome to part three of game theory
in breaking bad
the scene we're going to discuss now is
one of the most dramatic scenes and one
of the best examples of game theory
and it really speaks for itself
so we'll quickly just set up what's
going on and you should enjoy and watch
the clip
this scene takes place just before the
gun scene in the episode crazy handful
of nothing
the background is that jesse has tried
to meet with tuko and conduct a business
deal but tuko is a ruthless drug lord
and
he steals their product and he beats up
jesse to a bloody pulp
so walt is cornered he needs to figure
out a way that he can not only get money
for the product that tuko stole but he
also wants to be in business so that he
can make money
so how's he gonna do this
we'll see the action that walt takes
all right now let's do an analysis of
the scene
an important detail
in walt's meeting
is that to go first extinguishes a
cigarette in his mouth this is a classic
tough guy move tuka wants to show that
he can't be intimidated that he
is the one who holds the power
so although walt tries to reason
he's only going to get through if he can
demonstrate he can be a tough guy as
well
so what walt does is he uses the
strategy of mutually assured destruction
the idea
is that
he walt is willing to go nuclear he has
enough firepower
that can destroy everyone and if tuko
isn't willing to play game then walt is
just going to take actions and
everyone's going to be
decimated
the key to mutually assured destruction
is that walt has to show us threat as
credible
and he takes that in dramatic fashion
so it's that small explosion which
demonstrates walt means business and
that's why tuko relents
the idea that you can create a
reputation
is something that will expand on
and something that walt learns from tuko
in part four
thanks for watching this video you can
find me on mind your decisions or on
twitter at preshtalwalker